my mom came in town uh
you know i was definitely excited you
know i i saved some things at home
for us to do together like just to go
shopping for small
things and not even save them i think i
just hadn't done them
so you know it was nice uh to spend time
together i thought about having her as a
guest on the podcast but
we don't really have it set up right now
to do two people uh so we're gonna have
to wait uh
maybe another time um
you know there were sometimes it was a
little stressful and we kind of just
went to our
mutual corners and uh and that was okay
you know
um you know it was kind of nice in a lot
of ways man
it was nice just like i think i kind of
come to some realizations that like
you know my relationship with my mother
doesn't it doesn't have to be some
perfect thing
you know i think always in my head that
it needs to land in some perfect place
or it all has to be figured out
um and it's okay
it can kind of be that's that skill saw
it can kind of be um
you know it can just be kind of fluid
and uh and so there was nice
there was some niceness about that you
know there was some niceness just to
have
some times also i was like you know i
just need some space to myself
and i'm an adult now so i could do that
i could take that space
where when i was a child i didn't really
have that ability if i needed
you know if you know you're you're kind
of
in your parents you know you're in their
domain so um
so it was good man we went picked out
some different stuff and got some
different thing got some soap got a
shower caddy in my shower
because everything was just sitting on
the bottom you know when you're kind of
lit you know just two-stepping around
the toothpaste and all of that
and just trying to kick stuff away from
the drain
if you've ever done that in your shower
you just like don't set anything up so
it's just in the bottom you just keep
kicking it away from the drain but
um got a shower caddy forgot silverware
so still doing uh
you know still washing the plastics off
in the sink but um
but it was nice we didn't have really
like any heart-to-heart convos or
anything like that
you know and that's okay um
i'm glad that we both made the time to
spend time together though
you know we both made a commitment to to
spend time together
and um
and it was nice man we went out one
night mom had a margarita her second one
she's ever had
so that was cool so i had to put i had
to ask her some you know
ask her some questions about that about
her first marriage after that
and so you know i got into that a little
but um
yeah we had a nice time man i know that
she loves me and uh
you know and i'm hard to love sometimes
you know i'm particular
as an adult and i think they were those
were safety mechanisms that i used as a
kid
uh and now they sometimes keep me too
safe
in some ways you know they can sometimes
keep me so safe that uh
i'm separate um
but that's okay i'm not complaining
people sometimes are like man
you're whining i'm not having self-pity
i'm just sometimes i like to share what
i'm
thinking or feeling and it's not
complaining it's not
i'm just sharing it you know i just i i
just
i'm just sharing it and so that's okay
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one
you